[Music]
here in this video we are going to take
a look at 11 new dinosaurs and other
species from the jurassic world dominion
that were cloned by the company biosyn
not taking into account the ones that
were made by the other company called
engine
which were captured specimens and
transported it to the biosin valley
later on here we'll be looking at just
the ones made by biosin so let's get to
it
number one the morris intrepidus this is
a small tyrannosaurus dinosaur that was
seen first in the prologue of dominion
and later was seen in the bison lab in
the valley
morris represents the earliest known
diagnostic tyrannosaurid material from
the cretaceous of north america by a
margin of about 15 million years
to others as compared to others it is
small about 1.2 meters or 4 feet long
bipedal and carnivorous as well as
sharing a symbiotic relationship with
apex predators such as the
giganotosaurus back in the past
number 2 the giganotosaurus or the
giganotosaurus the apex predator the
largest land carnivore as stated in the
movie
the giganotosaurus was a bison original
dinosaur that was cloned
and not an indian one it was cloned and
bred by biosin itself it was also first
seen in the prologue and then became an
antagonist in the movie it was larger
and more powerful than the t-rex it
stood taller than rexy and longer at
around 15 meters or 50 feet long it has
an armored crocodilian-like skin and
also small spikes at the back
number three dimetrodon this species was
a pelicasaur one of a number of animals
known as mammal-like reptiles also
called synapsids that dominated the late
permian period it was a large carnivore
for its time that lived primarily in
swampy areas but was seen inhabiting
caves in the movie and it had a very
interesting feature a large sail on its
back similar to that of a spinosaurus
it was cloned by bison it was 3.5 meters
or 11 feet long and hunted in bags
number 4 the quetzalcoatlus another
biosin product that wasn't a dinosaur
but a close relative of them and
nonetheless quetzalcoatlus was a large
pterosaur probably the largest flying
creature ever it was first seen in the
prologue and then later in the movie as
it attacked a plane that owen and claire
were in this gigantic flying animal was
stated to be 5.4 meters or 18 feet tall
and had a wingspan of 12 meters or 40
feet but looked to be at least twice as
big when compared to the aeroplane in
the tank
number five the atrocious raptors where
engine failed in the velociraptors and
the indoraptor biosin succeeded in the
atrociraptors
they were trained killing machines and
attacked and ripped apart anyone painted
by a laser they were roughly the same
size as a velociraptor but maybe less
intelligent but highly effective hunters
one feature that defines the dromuzar
the atrociraptor from other general
is it's somewhat short and tall skull
that has a lot of serrated teeth
number six dread nordis yet another one
that was seen first in the prologue the
dreadnoughtus was the biggest dancer of
the movie maybe at par with the
brachiosaurus or maybe even bigger this
dinosaur was 30 feet tall or 9 meters
85 feet long or 26 meters and weighed a
record-breaking 65 tons it is an extinct
genus of titanosaur sauropod dinosaur
that lived in south america
during the late cretaceous period even
though the embryo for the specimen was
probably sold at the auction in fallen
kingdom it was however bred
and made its first appearance in the
bison valley so technically a bison
original
number seven the lystrosaurus this is a
genus of small dicinodon terrapsid that
originated in the late permian to the
early triassic it was believed to live
in what is now known as antarctica also
seen in india china mongolia european
russia and south africa thus proving in
a way the theory of continental drift
lystrosaurus appears in jurassic world
dominion as it was sold in a black
market of dinosaurs in valletta in malta
it is a small creature around two to
three feet long a little less than one
meter long
number eight the pyro raptor this was a
small farce hunter that lived near the
end of the age of the dinosaurs it was
the first raptor species in the
franchise that was fully covered in
feathers a pyroraptor was cloned by
bison and released to live within their
sanctuary where he lived atop the frozen
lake held behind the valley's dam
its feathers were primarily red ending
in darker and greyish ones it was
smaller than the velociraptor just a
little bit smaller being eight feet long
and was a surprisingly agile swimmer
number nine the theory xenosaurus no
doubt the star dancer of the show the
therizinosaurus was a big herbivorous
dinosaur but it was also a highly
territorial one making it a very
dangerous creature that can't kill
anything with a swipe of its one meter
long claw
the specimen at bison valley was 5 to 6
meters or close to 20 feet tall it was
also 40 feet long
or 12 meters almost as long as the t-rex
and weight 6 stuns it however was blind
and relied on echolocation to survive
thereby
explaining the sounds it makes
spoiler alert it stop stab the largest
carnivore to death
number 10 the iguanodon also another one
seen first in the prologue just before
the
[ __ ] notosaurus and the t-rex fought
to their death
this dinosaur the last dinosaur species
on this list
that were created by bison was a
herbivore and a big one as well it was
around 43 feet long
or more than 13 meters or almost as long
as a t-rex and also with a similar
weight close to 5-6 tons the iguanodons
were seen running to the emergency
center at the later part of the movie
the most peculiar aspect of this
dinosaur is the gangster sign it does
with its thumb and pinky finger
do check it out
and lastly 11 the giant locus
so these are unidentified species of
large extinct locus which are
genetically altered
that appeared in the movie the they are
locus from the lake cretaceous as we can
tell and their dna were altered to be
stronger and therefore made them more
resilient to pesticides and poisons and
even some resilience to fire
these giant locusts were the main
overarching doomsday threat of the movie
created specifically by dodson to cause
worldwide famine and for bison to take
control of food production therefore
ruling the world
these large locusts were more than 30
centimeters or one feet long and can
breed like a village family on steroids
of course there were more dinosaurs that
appeared in the movie like the pack of
dilophosauruses
the old ones like rexy and the two other
t-rex seen in the end credit scenes as
well as classics like the pteranodons
and triceratops but they were all engine
dinos
so yeah these weren't biosin ones
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so tell us what you think
and do hit that like button for support
oh yeah subscribe as well to be a part
of the mind cue family and click that
bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam